California governor Gavin Newsom is
picking a fight with America's most
popular podcasters Newsome is terrified
that his son is listening to Joe Rogan
and Jordan Peterson saying in an
interview quote I really worry about
these micro Cults that my kids are in my
son is asking me about Andrew Tate
Jordan Peterson and then immediately
he's talking about Joe Rogan and I'm
like here it is the pathway
it comes as no shock Joe Rogan has
recently blamed Gavin Newsom for ruining
California
it's California and Justin Trudeau it's
Gavin Newsom the problem is uh he did
such a bad job with California it's so
they're so vulnerable
Madness yeah close there's so many
businesses that are closing down they
don't want to be a part of it anymore
like hey we need to take care of
disenfranchised people but we also need
to make our streets safe and we have to
stop crime and there's no none of that
there's like more ridiculous laws more
lacks on crime more money for the
homeless people give them free drug give
them needles they need clean needles
like what
Greg what do you think about Gavin
Newsom lamenting that his son this is
wonderful first of all let's examine
what a cult really is a cult tells you
who you can and cannot talk to it
ostracizes people that aren't in the
cold that is not Jordan Peterson that is
not Joe Rogan they actually go out and
interview people and they tell people to
talk to different people I don't know
enough about Andrew Tate but I want to
quote Scott Adams because this is a
really smart point the more that the
left tries to raise the children of the
right the more Andrew Tate will be
raising children of the left and that
appears to be happening with Gavin
Newsom because his own intolerance is
forcing his kids to look elsewhere
meanwhile there is a movement uh that
that tells you who you can't and cannot
talk to and ostracizes people it's a
progressive woke Democrats cancer
culture's primary engine is ostracizing
people Washington Post chase down
portnoy's advertisers to get them away
from him all right people actually go
and look at your Twitter follows and
then they interview you and go why do
you follow this person why do you follow
that they cancel speeches they ask you
why you would go to that speech they
target Trump supporters for for voting
for Trump why would you vote for him
it's Rich that Newsome calls these
people a cult when his own party is
rebirthing McCarthyism right they now
look at First Amendment as something
that's malleable and not absolute it
easily discarded Gavin should look in
the mirror and not just to check his
hair Jesse did Newsome have to offend
his listeners too with these comments
well I would say that the tennis pro has
been serving up a lot of disinformation
himself everything he said about the
vaccines about school closures I mean he
put sand in skate parks so people had to
go inside mask mandates remember how he
used to go after hydroxychloroquine he
was going after doctors for prescribing
it the Mayo Clinic just put
hydroxychloroquine back on the treatment
list for
covid-19 so he was wrong about
everything so you have a guy like
Peterson who whose whole advocacy is
rooted in the classics he's all about
self-improvement I mean what is Gavin
want his son to watch sports center or
listen to Jordan Peterson and then you
have Rogan as Greg said the guy
interviews UFC fighters Comics uh
astrophysicists Wildlife Trappers
there's nothing controversial about him
all he does is listen and one of the
reasons people are so attracted to him
is because everybody's controversialized
these people because the professional
class has told the entire population of
this generation to be passive and to not
question authority so these two guys
come along and they say we got to take
action we got a question authority
that's why Young Americans are so
thirsty for some sort of Elder Statesman
to say this is a way that you can gain a
frame of reference and interpret the
world around you instead of just having
propaganda wash over you like a slave
Harold does it concern you that a real
clear politics poll just revealed that
nearly half of Democrats say Free Speech
should be legal only under certain
circumstances and 34 percent of
Democrats say America's Americans have
too much freedom
sure that would that would concern me uh
and and there are a lot of things that
concern me I think that with Gavin
Newsom making his comment about uh his
his son and listening to whomever they
may be listening to you know I think in
a weird way it's positive because I like
the idea of people not reacting so much
but responding to things they hear so I
think we live in a society today where
you immediately react as if I hear
you're Republican or you're a Democrat
or you're a conservative or you're
whiter you're black or you're this that
I'm supposed to respond in certain way
as opposed to say let me sit back
um listen to them and then respond
accordingly I'd be curious to know and
I'm sure I hope the governor's share all
the things are happening yeah for these
kids but I think it's a positive that
his kids are able to have that kind of a
mind and I hope that kids are on the
other side I think your point uh um Greg
was an interesting one you think you're
quoting someone sending the kids on the
left they're gonna be raised by people
on the right and vice versa look I grew
up and I listened to all kinds of
political thought I listen to all kind
of political leaders I was intrigued by
Ronald Reagan growing up my dad was in
Congress he sometimes didn't like Ronald
Reagan and what it would and they would
bow a bit when he was in Congress but I
listened in red I think it's the only
way you can grow and there are some
things that Joe Rogan say might be out
of bounds I don't know maybe they are
there's some things that people that I
like or agree with more more likely not
out of Bounds at times probably so but
that's the beauty of being an American
and being able to listen to and
hopefully respond after you listen judge
your thoughts you know if you think that
uh Joe Rogan and Jordan Peterson are
part of a micro cult well the Democrat
Party is a macro cult and it's evidenced
by the fact that almost half of the
party says that Free Speech should only
be under certain circumstances folks
that is totalitarianism that is what
Democrats are thinking they say that
government has a responsibility to
censor hateful social media 75 so when
the government was censoring
hydroxychloroquine which Jesse just
brought up is like back on the list
again from something that we can take
the government was wrong and they
censored us and what's going on here I
don't know what Gavin Newsom is so
afraid of that his son might think for
himself that his son might he have two
different points of view and the idea
that you know the left is so radical
that anything that isn't woke is
considered conservative so if you're not
cuckoo left you're a conservative and
that's why right now we're seeing a
20-point lead of trump over Biden as it
relates to the young people they and by
the way they are totally ignorant of the
law of the Constitution there's nothing
in the Constitution other than you know
calling people to Riot or yelling fire
in a crowded uh theater that says that
that we can't say whatever we want
people are crawling through the borders
of this country so that they can say
whatever they want and this Democrat
totalitarian party wants to shut
Americans up we can't afford that all
right thank you very much for that judge
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 pm Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights